veterans welcome back to the forge on
your anvils is a cloth go ahead and lift
that up
those are stacks of 15 and 20 and 1095
steel that you will use to make a
Damascus Billet and a pattern of your
choosing from which you will Forge one
of these
M3 trench knife
the M3 trench knife was issued to U.S
military personnel beginning in March
1943 seeing widespread use throughout
the branches and in particular with
Elite Airborne forces and Army Rangers
built as a World War II fighting knife
these blades were light and sharp ideal
for thrusting stabbing and even throwing
and served as the base design for future
bayonets
they must have a false Edge that runs at
least one-third the length of the blade
must have a through tang and an acid
etch gentlemen we don't want you to make
an original M3 we don't want your
interpretation of an M3 we want this M3
good luck your three hour Starts Now
making Damascus is one of the reasons I
got into bladesmithing because not
everybody can make Damascus and no two
Damascus blades are alike the most
important thing for me right now is
start cleaning that steel up how
critical is the cleanliness of the steel
it's essential I mean if you don't have
clean steel you don't get clean Wells
the thing we have in the Army is
pissport preparation leads to piss for
execution so if I can plan right things
will come out great with Damascus I'm
fairly comfortable I think I've got the
process pretty well down right now it's
just waiting for it to warm up Let it
soak a little bit then run it over to
the press and set the welds I feel like
I'm falling a little bit behind but I
know how fast this can go once I get it
to where I want it to be
it's really important to me to make sure
that that Forge weld is set
everything's looking nice and solid
if you have a clean weld on the first
forged weld do you put yourself at risk
by going for another fold that
ultimately has no bearing on whether or
not you move forward in the competition
I would it's a demonstration of skill
and I think it looks better in the end
this isn't the time to play it safe this
is the chance for me to step up and
represent the army with the best of my
game restack this Billet and kick some
ass
my plan right now is basically retack it
go for some more layers
this is the Championships I can't sit
there and turn in a 12 layer if
everybody else is turning in 30 40. I'm
worried that Mike didn't do enough
cleanup or on those pieces of Steel
after he cut them apart we're ready to
start drawing out the second cut and
stack Billet on the Press
damn it I opened up
back side of it splits open
Mike could have a serious problem I Mean
Gene opted to just restart he saw the
scenes were bad only Superior work is
going to move forward in this
competition Why not start over I would
have cost it started again
I don't even want to move
there's fifty thousand dollars on the
line here I don't want to go home Mike
is looking to set that
that's worrying me
come on get hot I found that yelling at
my Forge rarely heats the metal but it
does make me feel a lot better yeah my
goal is to get it to the finished blade
and I got a lot of meat to remove in a
very short amount of time and I still
have to heat treat it and I still have
to etch it
quench had a Tyler over here it looked
like he did a combination quench prayer
I'm going to be in here for a couple
seconds I'm just going to take a break
and let this happen and I'm never one to
pull it out fast I like to let it cool
get nice and hard blade is perfectly
straight it's time to grind
oxycetylene torch you're doing an edge
planche yeah they Edge quench leaves the
spine still flexible but strong and it
leaves the edge rock hard there he is
he's in the quench
this thing has to go in the quench
of course it catches fire
oh yeah that's hard
I'm happy back to the grinder
three two one blade Smith shut down your
machines drop your tools stop what
you're doing this first round of
competition is over
[Applause]
late Smith's to test the strength and
durability of your blades I'm going to
be bashing and stabbing into these oil
cans
Jane you're up let's do this Ben
's going to take it and try to do
everything he can to break it and he's
not gonna show any Mercy whatsoever I
have a hard time watching it
[Music]
Gene your tip
held up really well in the stabs your
Edge however there's chips and rolls
here but that being said the whole thing
held up nice job thank you Tyler you're
up next you ready yep let's do it
I feel pretty good I've got a lot of
meat in the tip of that blade to keep it
nice and strong
[Music]
it's amazing
well Tyler
your blade held up really well in this
test your s guard here is more like a
z-guard but all told well done thanks
Mike you're up how you feeling
not great but we got to do it now it's
my turn that I'm just dreading it
something was to go wrong I think my
Palma will probably pop off
I think I'm probably going home
wow
well Mike you hear that
sir that's your Palmer your finer fixed
blades have no moving Parts this now
does but your Edge held up fine in this
test and you've still got one knife so
well done thank you sir all right
veterans this is the sharpness test the
Sandman slice
[Music]
it's all about what the edge of your
blade will do to the Sandman Genie up
first you ready let's do this Doug
[Music]
oh
yeah
nice job all right Gene despite having
some glinting and some rolls here did
not affect the cut at all your stabbing
Point thrust easily on this overall sir
your weapon it will cut yes
all right Tyler your turn are you ready
I'm ready for it
foreign
all right Tyler but what I like about
your blade is the combat balance it's us
easily going forward as it is going back
thrust in thrust out overall sir your
weapon it will cut excellent all right
Mike are you ready absolutely let's do
this
foreign
[Music]
your edge here has one section here that
is not sharp at all your point is sharp
enough for thrusting coming out if it
doesn't catch this edge here you can see
that this part here that's dull actually
ripped rather than cut this material but
overall it will come thank you
blade Smith's your weapons have been
tested and the judges have weighed in
and made their final decision and let's
not sugarcoat a gentlemen
Mike your blade didn't make the cut Ben
avid's going to tell you why
well my first of all I'd like to thank
you for your service
and it's a testament to your abilities
that you've made it this far in this
competition thank you but we're not
Cloud kit zero you just weren't finished
there were sharp Parts on your handle
that bothered both Doug and myself it's
for that reason we're letting you go
Mike please surrender your blade
the judges couldn't have made any other
decision I'm proud of the way I
represented the Air Force everything
doesn't always go our way but it's how
you handle your challenges how you
adjust how you adapt that really tells
the tailor Who You Are